on va débuter notre réunion commission
mes chers collègues nous accèvrons
aujourd'hui notre cycle d'audition
audition consacrée à l'avenir des
concessions autoroutières après avoir
entendu les auteurs du rapport de la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale sur le
sujet les dirigeants des sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute et des
représentants des trois associations
d'usagers
des autoroutes Bernard romans et plus
récemment Philippe ricert le
vice-président et président par intérim
de l'Autorité de régulation des
transports la RT nous accueillons
Monsieur Patrice verger président du
conseil d'administration de l'Agence de
financement des infrastructures de
transport de France
Lafitte depuis janvier 2023
monsieur le Président c'est avec plaisir
que nous vous recevons ce matin après de
six mois après vous avoir auditionné en
tant que candidat à la présidence du
conseil d'administration de la fille de
France une candidature que les membres
de cette commission avait d'ailleurs
largement approuvé
avant toute chose rappelons que la fille
de France est un établissement public
administratif dans le coeur de métier et
le financement des infrastructures de
transport elle est notamment chargée de
financer au nom de l'État les grands
projets d'infrastructures et de mobilité
mais aussi la part de l'État dans le
contrat de plan est à région ainsi que
d'assurer les investissements de
régénération et ou de sécurisation des
réseaux routiers ferroviaires ou fluvien
vous avez pris la tête de la fuite un
mancharnière pour les transports de et
pour l'agence d'une part le volet
mobilité des CPER pour la période 2023
2027 est désormais en cours de
négociation au niveau local d'autre part
quelques mois après la publication du
rapport du Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures au coi le gouvernement
devrait soumettre au Parlement une
nouvelle loi d'orientation des mobilités
devant fixer un cap à la programmation
des investissements en matière
d'infrastructures
de transport pour les 10 prochaines
années les besoins s'annoncent colossaux
le COI identifie un mur d'investissement
de 200 milliards d'euros à l'horizon
2030 en conséquence la première ministre
a annoncé en février dernier un plan
d'avenir pour les transports à hauteur
de 100 milliards d'euros d'ici 2040
si on ne peut que se réjouir de cette
prise de conscience de la part des
exécutif la trajectoire d'investissement
qui s'annonce renforce les inquiétudes
inquiétudes qui pèsent sur le modèle de
financement de la fuite dont les
recettes demeurent toujours incertaine
rappelons-le le produit des amendes
radar dans l'agence ne perçoit qu'une
par résiduelle a été à moindre riz
durant la crise des gilets jaunes tandis
que la taxe sur les billets d'avion
avait été différé jusqu'en 2022 du fait
de la crise sanitaire enfin les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute refusent de
s'acquitter du versement à l'agence de
la contribution volontaire
exceptionnelle depuis 2021 dans ce
contexte la taxe intérieure de
consommation sur les produits
énergétiques TICPE constituent la
recette la plus stable de la fuite alors
même qu'elle est vouée à une attribution
progressive étant donné l'objectif de
décarbonation du secteur des transports
je vous propose aujourd'hui d'aborder
deux sujets à la lumière de ces états de
Dieu
premièrement cette audition ne pouvait
pas mieux tomber puisque le rapport
d'activité de la fuite pour l'année 2022
vient d'être publiée nous serions
heureux que vous puissiez nous en
présenter aujourd'hui les principales
orientations et éventuellement les
points vigilance point de vigilance que
nous pourrions relayer dans le cadre de
l'examen du projet de loi de finance
pour 2024 ou de la future l'homme
deuxièmement et c'est le sujet central
de votre présence parmi nous nous
souhaitons aborder l'arrivée à échéance
des contrats de concession autoroutière
sujet qui aura de fortes incidences sur
la fuite France et plus globalement sur
le modèle de financement des
infrastructures de transport avant de
laisser lancer le débat j'aurais trois
questions à vous soumettre s'agissant
des concessions autoroutières
premièrement comment devrions-nous
anticiper les chances des contrats de
concession en cours le rapport du coi
expose trois scénarios alternatifs pour
gérer la fin des concessions la
poursuite du modèle actuel la reprise
des infrastructures concédées par un
gestionnaire national ou enfin leur
décentralisation échéance aux régions
qu'elles desservent quel article quelle
alternative vous semblerait la plus
pertinente afin de sécuriser le modèle
de financement des transports
deuxièmement l'arrivée à échéance des
contrats de concession associé à la
réduction annoncée du produit de la
ti-cpe va constituer un véritable défi
pour le financement de la fuite Jean
Castex qui vous a brièvement précédé à
la tête de cet institution avait évoqué
devant nous la nécessité d'être plus
imaginatif et d'identifier de nouvelles
recettes affectées avez-vous des
propositions informées afin d'assurer
des ressources pérennes à l'agence
enfin comment comme vous le savez la
question de la contribution du secteur
des autoroutes au financement d'autres
modèles de transport est actuellement au
cœur des débats alors qu'un rapport de
l'Inspection générale des finances a été
pointée du doigt a pointé du doigt la
rentabilité excessive des sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute en début
d'année le gouvernement a consulté le
Conseil d'État afin d'expertiser deux
options pour rééquilibrer les choses un
raccourcissement de la durée des
concessions en cours ou une contribution
fiscale supplémentaire
selon des informations parues dans la
presse la semaine dernière la haute
juridiction aurait exclu la première
option mais ce serait montré favorable à
la seconde or dès le mois d'avril VINCI
Autoroutes a fait savoir qu'en cas de
hausse de la fiscalité pesant sur les
SCA elle demanderait le remboursement de
la contribution volontaire
exceptionnelle versée depuis 2004 sans
environ 420 millions d'euros
pour rappeler les termes du débat
Philippe Richard président par intérim
de la RTA souligné à la semaine dernière
que si les SCA contribué au financement
de la fuite à hauteur de près de 930
millions d'euros au titre de la taxe
d'aménagement du territoire et de la
redevance de manière la baisse d'impôt
sur les sociétés dont elle bénéficie
depuis 2018 leur permis d'économiser
près de 7,9 milliards d'euros dans ce
contexte comment envisagez-vous un
éventuel renforcement de la pression
fiscale pesant sur les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute
identifiez-vous parmi nos voisins
européens des modèles dont nous
pourrions nous inspirer pour que le
secteur autoroutier mais aussi l'aérien
contribue davantage au financement des
modes de transport plus vertueux
conformément aux annonces de la première
ministre dans le cadre du plan d'avenir
pour les transports
monsieur le Président je vous remercie
de votre attention et je vous laisserai
répondre à ces quelques questions et
évoquer le rapport d'activités de la
fuite dans l'ordre qu'il vous semble
plus opportun ensuite je céderai la
parole à mes collègues afin qu'il
réagissent sur ces différents points je
plaisant je vous donne la parole
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement comme vous l'avez rappelé
j'étais venu devant vous au mois de
janvier et votre commission avait
largement approuvé ma désignation à la
tête de la fidélité et je tiens à
remercier l'ensemble des sénateurs pour
cette pour cette confiance évidemment à
ce moment-là je vous avais je m'étais
engagé à justement jouer le jeu de la
transparence et j'avais dit
effectivement que chaque année au moment
de la sortie du rapport d'activité je
reviendrai vers vous je reviendrai dans
cette commission justement pour pouvoir
avoir un débat sur sur le rapport
d'activité c'est la première fois que
j'ai donc l'occasion de le faire sur une
année 2022 où je n'étais je n'ai pas été
une journée président du Conseil
administration de Lafitte donc c'est un
exercice un peu particulier mais qui
permettra finalement de de se donner les
ambitions ou les moyens de ce que on
pourrait faire les années suivantes si
vous avez des suggestions ou des choses
que vous voir chaque année dans le dans
le rapport d'activités de la fuite c'est
le moment de le dire et dans ce cas là
je m'engagerai évidemment pour l'année
2024 sur le rapport d'activité 2023 à
donner l'ensemble des éléments que vous
pourriez solliciter donc ce jeu de la
transparence était un engagement de ma
part et c'est aussi ma première raison
de ma venue en plus évidemment de toute
la réflexion que vous menez sur l'avenir
des concessions au SC
je commencerai donc par le rapport
d'activités de la fille vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président c'est un
je l'avais d'ailleurs évoqué au mois de
janvier on avait dit c'est un c'est un
semestre qui sera particulièrement
chargé en réflexion en annonce autour de
problématiques des infrastructures de
transport on a eu effectivement le
rapport du coi et ce fameux mur
d'investissement je pense que le grand
avantage du rapport du coi c'est que
finalement il donne une bon état j'ai
envie de dire de la situation des
dépenses on a eu les de la première
ministre on a eu le plan vélo on a eu
encore récemment le président de la
République a pris des engagements sur le
transport à Marseille on a ce débat
autour de programmation ou actualisation
de la Lomme je rajouterai à ça
l'émission sur les etfus les feux pardon
les RER métropolitains le financement
des OEM donc effectivement on a un
semestre qui a été particulièrement
chargé en matière d'actualité autour des
transports le rapport d'activité de la
fuite 2022
est à la hauteur finalement des
ambitions qui lui étaient alloué par la
Lom puisque le budget 2022 de la fuite
est un budget record à 3,3 milliards
d'euros en crédit de paiement je
rappelle que finalement en 2016 c'était
simplement 2,1 milliard d'euros ça note
la progression effectivement du budget
de la fuite en matière d'infrastructure
de transport et finalement ça correspond
à cette tendance que qui évoque dans son
rapport le le COI sur la nécessité
effectivement d'augmenter demain les
dépenses en matière d'infrastructure de
transport la bonne nouvelle parce que ça
avait déjà été pointé du doigt par le
passé c'est que 2022 dans en 2022 ce
budget a été exécuté à hauteur de
99,08 %. donc on a finalement un budget
totalement exécuté au niveau de la file
ce qui est quand même finalement la la
première la première exigence qu'on peut
avoir de la fuite c'est pouvoir exécuter
les dépenses en l'occurrence le taux de
99,08 et particulièrement satisfaisant
et répond en tout cas à une attente qui
était exprimée au cours des années
précédentes donc je veux évidemment
féliciter mes prédécesseurs pour avoir
réussi à mettre à ce niveau de
d'exécution de budget Lafitte
ce qui est intéressant à noter dans le
rapport mais vous l'avez d'ailleurs
monsieur le Président je vous en
laisserai un rapport totalement
m'inquiété et voilà donc vous l'aurez
vous l'aurez de cette manière ce qui est
intéressant à noter dans ce rapport
c'est finalement dans ces dépenses de la
fuite on retrouve à peu près un tiers
pour les infrastructures routières et
deux tiers pour les modes alternatifs à
la route ce qui était ce qui est
effectivement l'une des orientations
définies pour la fille définie par la
l'homme que d'essayer effectivement de
de prendre notamment sur les mobilités
carbonées pour réallouer aux
infrastructures de transport des
mobilités des carbonées le 1/3 de route
me paraît cohérent parce qu'il ne s'agit
pas d'arriver à zéro la route elle aussi
a engager sa décarbonation
on a des enjeux autour de
l'électrification des modes routiers on
a des enjeux autour des du covoiturage
des voies réservées même de l'évolution
des routes pour la préservation de la
ressource en eau la lutte contre le
bruit
les véhicules autonomes la contribution
aussi des routes demain à la production
énergétique donc effectivement il y a
des enjeux pour la route aussi dans la
décarbonation des transports et donc ce
1/3 de tiers me paraît particulièrement
bien équilibré au regard des enjeux des
enjeux de demain
finalement si je devais prendre un peu
de recul sur justement cette actualité
du 1er semestre et ce rapport d'activité
de Lafitte et c'est que finalement
aujourd'hui
le débat a permis d'avoir une bonne idée
de ce que doivent être les dépenses dans
les années qui viennent mais finalement
on
identifie pas encore les recettes qui
correspond le débat je trouve qu'il
s'ouvre aujourd'hui c'est la question
des recettes en face des dépenses donc
les dépenses mais dire le rapport du coi
a bien identifié les choses mais
maintenant comment on va on va financer
tout ça et je pense qu'on est on est au
niveau du on est on est un bon niveau de
débat aujourd'hui quand on quand on
s'intéresse aux recettes comme vous
l'avez fait monsieur le président
pour la fille qui a un enjeu important
il y a d'abord évidemment le montant
c'est-à-dire qu'effectivement mur
d'investissement implique à haut niveau
de recettes
il y a aussi une autre une autre
condition me semble-t-il et lorsque lors
de mes de mes rencontres avec les
différents acteurs c'est la question de
l'annulalité budgétaire et la question
de la visibilité à long terme des
dépenses en matière d'infrastructure de
transport tous les acteurs et en
particulier quand on s'intéresse aux
mobilités des carbonées donc notamment
le rail tous les acteurs m'ont indiqué
la nécessité d'avoir une visibilité à 10
ans à 15 ans
des dépenses et donc des recettes liées
aux infrastructures de transport on ne
peut pas programmer la régénération du
rail sur des coûts d'accélération et de
ralentissement des investissements
dédiés aux infrastructures de transport
donc l'enjeu pour la fuite c'est non
seulement comment
identifier le bon niveau de recettes
pour répondre au bureau d'investissement
ce que vous avez évoqué mais comment
arrive-t-on à concilier annualité
budgétaire aire et visibilité à 10 15 20
ans sur les recettes affectées aux
infrastructures de transport et je pense
que c'est l'une des principales
questions posées aujourd'hui comment on
garantit un niveau de recettes
évidemment suffisant mais aussi une
continuité de ces recettes et donc des
dépenses qui sont afférentes pour cela
la fille peut être un outil à la
condition que la fuite se voit affecter
à mon avis
une taxe à 100% aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
le modèle des recettes de la fiche je
vais y venir mais si on identifie une
taxe relativement pérenne relativement
stable affectée à 100% à la fuite on
peut à la fois garantir ce haut niveau
de dépenses mais surtout une visibilité
qui pourrait alors qui est pas tout à
fait
dans le respect de la dualité budgétaire
mais qui pourrait en tout cas faire
l'objet d'un consensus politique autour
d'une continuité et d'une garantie dans
le temps ce qui me paraît absolument
aujourd'hui nécessaire si on veut
pouvoir engager la réponse au rapport du
coi sur les recettes de la ville j'y
reviens parce que je pense que le débat
est là on a les petites sommes
finalement l'avion aujourd'hui les
billets d'avion c'est 138 millions
effectivement vous l'avez évoqué
monsieur le Président la première
ministre l'a également évoqué 138
millions est-ce que c'est à la hauteur
des enjeux aujourd'hui de transfert de
cette mobilité carbonée vers le
décarboné on pourrait imaginer demain
quand même que cette peut-être plus
élevé en tout cas que les recettes
correspondant à 138 millions paraissent
peu élevés au regard des enjeux de
déplacement vers les mobilités des
carbonées les amandes radar c'est 178
millions voilà donc aujourd'hui sur ces
deux recettes nous avons retrouvé en
2022 le taux plein c'est à dire que
l'effet covid effectivement a disparu
donc ça vous donne effectivement une
idée de l'ampleur de ce recettes qui
paraissent quand même assez minime au
regard des enjeux qu'on a évoqué
aujourd'hui la TICPE vous l'avez évoqué
monsieur le Président ça représente 1,2
milliards ou à cela s'ajoute le plan de
relance de 660 millions on a là
effectivement des dépenses que vous êtes
qualifiées de j'ai envie de dire non
stable en tout cas non garanti pour pour
les années qui viennent et enfin les
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute à
peu près 1 milliard d'euros
donc c'est effectivement la
substantielle c'est un enjeu extrêmement
important de du financement des
infrastructures de transport l'avenir je
vous rappelle quand même le contentieux
que nous avons actuellement avec nos
sociétés concessionnaire d'autoroute à
hauteur de 122 millions de mémoire sur
les deux années 2022 et 2021 aujourd'hui
on est effectivement au contentieux pour
la contribution volontaire
exceptionnelle et ce déballage n'est à
mon avis pas complètement terminé mais
en tout cas aujourd'hui il obéir la
capacité d'investissement de la fille de
122 millions d'euros déjà et a priori en
2023 les sociétés concessionnaires
d'autoroute malgré le contexte que vous
avez évoqué dans toujours pas
l'intention de verser à la file cette
contribution volontaire exceptionnelle
et le contentieux risque de durer
la question que vous avez posée
finalement sur les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute elle est
elle est donc très importante pour la
fuite puisqu'il évidemment c'est une
source de financement qui paraît
absolument essentielle les questions les
questions qui sont posées finalement
derrière ça et derrière ce que vous avez
évoqué c'est une question de de justice
on sait qu'effectivement il faudra
beaucoup d'argent pour répondre à ce mur
d'investissement en matière
d'infrastructure de transport mais c'est
finalement qui doit payer pour
construire effectivement ce qui
permettra de pérenniser ces
investissements est-ce que ce sont les
usagers notamment les usagers des
sociétés d'autoroute ou est-ce que ce
sont les territoires nous voyons
aujourd'hui émerger des sociétés de
projets affectées à un certain nombre de
grands projets levés aujourd'hui des
taxes sur les territoires est-ce qu'on
doit assister à un transfert de l'usager
vers le contribuable contribuable local
c'est une question qui est posée
aujourd'hui en termes de justice
ce qui concerne les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute aujourd'hui
effectivement
la DG IDM le gouvernement ont engagé
aujourd'hui dès à présent la réflexion
sur l'évolution de ces concessions
d'autoroute ça me semble indispensable
parce que le délai que vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure monsieur le Président est
en réalité bien court et effectivement
il est temps aujourd'hui de pouvoir
engager la réflexion alors je rentrerai
pas forcément dans dans un mois
forcément de le faire de rentrer dans le
choix sur les différents scénarios qui
sont là mais en tout cas il y a des
questions de fond qui sont qui sont
posées finalement qui doit payer
davantage demain plutôt que il faut que
je termine vite je vais terminer vite ah
c'est pas bon moi qui doit payer
finalement le plus demain entre le
véhicule léger et le poids lourd c'est
une question qui est aujourd'hui posée
est-ce qu'on peut imaginer une
différence entre celui qui pratique la
courte distance et la longue distance
celui qui est concerné pour prendre
l'autoroute pour faire son domicile
travail qui de la route ou celui qui est
effectivement l'utilise pour le loisir
ces questions évidemment sont des
questions ouvertes aujourd'hui et je ne
trouverai pas inintéressante d'aller les
chercher et puis enfin il y a une
dernière question qui évidemment dans
cette assemblée toujours un peu sensible
mais les autres pays européens ont
choisi on choisit de ne pas cibler le
paiement de l'usager uniquement sur
l'autoroute mais finalement le poids
lourd qui utilise la route en France
pourquoi ne contribuerait-il pas aussi
finalement à l'avenir des
infrastructures de transport alors je
sais que le traumatisme des Bonnets
Rouges a été important en France je sais
pas cité le mot écodacle
j'ai dit qu'il y a traumatisme
effectivement à exister mais aujourd'hui
effectivement cette question cette
question de de du paiement
qui soit uniquement sur les autoroutes
françaises méritent en tout cas d'être
posée finalement pourquoi un poids lourd
qui traverse la France sur les routes
départementales ou les routes nationales
ne payent pas alors que celui qui prend
l'autoroute P donc ces questions de
justice et d'équité devant le paiement
et la recette nécessaire pour affronter
le mur d'investissement sont évidemment
posés je pense qu'effectivement ce qui
est important c'est de trouver
finalement une réponse juste en terme de
paiement et puis pour terminer vous avez
évoqué évidemment la question de la
rentabilité des sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute et ce que
ce qui a été qualifié de super profit le
gouvernement il travaille aujourd'hui
évidemment je ne verrai que d'un bon
oeil si une taxe additionnelle était
trouvée que ça puisse venir abonder le
budget de la ville parce qu'elle en a
besoin merci merci monsieur le Président
pour ce propos luminaire vos réponses je
vais donner la parole à Olivier Jacquin
merci président merci Patrice hergrid
pour ses explications et cette prise en
main de de la fille dans une période où
il y a effectivement des réflexions
assez importantes nous portons avec mon
groupe une réflexion sur l'avenir des
contrats autoroutiers qui doivent se
préparer longtemps à l'avance je
rappelle ce que disait l'ancien
président de la RT que de nouveaux
contrats c'est trois ans de préparation
deux ans pour lancer les les offres et
donc c'est il faut véritablement
anticiper ça nous portons une
proposition qui viserait à créer un
établissement public route de France qui
porterait l'ensemble du réseau routier
national non concédé et le réseau
routier
concédé à l'issue des contrats donc sans
indemnité et ces excédents pourraient
dans le cadre d'une nouvelle euro
redevance qui se généraliser à l'issue
des péages pourrait financer la fille
d'une manière tout à fait stable je dois
rencontrer le ministre Clément bonne
pour évoquer ce projet prochainement
mais au vu de ces dernières déclarations
ce dimanche sur RTL il s'est
enfin
clairement exprimé en faveur du modèle
concessif pour poursuivre cette gestion
autoroutière je voudrais votre avis sur
un projet du style route de France
notamment je vous remercie
merci je vais donner la parole à
Guillaume Chevrollier
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la fuite donc l'Agence de
financement des infrastructures de
transport j'aurais profité de votre
audition pour pour faire état de la
situation de la région des Pays de la
Loire suite à l'abandon du projet
Notre-Dame-des-Landes et 4 ans après un
contrat d'avenir avait été signé entre
l'État et la région pour obtenir des
décompensations pour obtenir du
financement et
réaménagement de l'aéroport de Nantes
Atlantique ce qui aujourd'hui est
toujours au statu quo donc si ce qui
n'est pas acceptable alors c'est pas
dans dans le dans les compétences de la
fuite forcément les aéroports mais il y
a à côté des aéroports il y a aussi le
renforcement de la liaison TGV Paris Le
Mans Angers à Nantes avec aussi une
virgule qui qui permet la desserte du
très beau département de la Mayenne et
aujourd'hui il y a une forte attente des
collectivités locales pour avoir un
soutien financier alors il y a vous
l'avez évoqué le volet mobilité du CPER
les compensations sont attendues donc
quel engagement on peut obtenir de votre
part pour qu'il y ait ce soutien à la
région des Pays de la Loire qui a vu un
projet d'envergure abandonné et qui
attend décompensation sur la LGV mais
également
le TER tant dans le la régénération la
sécurisation des voies et puis également
puisqu'on a un flux important de
passagers il faut aussi avoir des rames
supplémentaires pour satisfaire les
besoins de mobilité décarbonée des
ligériens merci
je vais donner la parole à Hervé gilet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de Lafitte je vous ai écouté
donc avec beaucoup d'attention et dans
la continuité de l'intervention de mon
collègue Olivier Jacquin je voudrais
avoir quelques précisions donc vous
souhaitez qui est donc une taxe qui soit
directement infectée à la fuite pour
consolider ses financements est-ce que
vous pouvez nous préciser de quelle
manière vous souhaitez que cette taxe
soit levée sur quelle base sur quelle
assiette ce serait un élément assez
déterminant pour qu'on puisse se
projeter dans l'avenir et voir de quelle
manière au niveau parlementaire nous
pourrions vous accompagner vous avez mis
en perspective donc le taux d'exécution
qui est effectivement particulièrement
significatif mais sur la qualité du
reporting à chaque fois et ça concerne
pas uniquement la fuite on s'interroge
toujours pour avoir les bonnes
équivalences tout d'abord avec une
inflation qui est relativement forte le
reconstant et aujourd'hui
particulièrement important donc il faut
comparer ce qui est comparable en termes
de réalisation des travaux et par
rapport à des surcos qui aujourd'hui
impactent l'ensemble des projets donc il
serait pertinent je pense d'avoir des
précisions sur ces sujets là et enfin on
peut avoir un taux d'exécution important
mais en même temps un programme de
travaux qui est inscrit qui est en deçà
désespérance
donc les dérapages calendaires sont
également des sujets qui sont
particulièrement importants dans le
domaine des transports est-ce que vous
avez aujourd'hui des éléments de mesure
également une qualité de reporting qui
nous permettrait de mieux apprécier
entre ce qui a été prévu ce qui se
réalise effectivement
et donc des taux d'exécution qu'on peut
inscrire au niveau annuel mais qui
comporte quand même en même temps des
reports de projets par ailleurs sur
plusieurs exercices je vous remercie
mettez rien je vous laisse répondre à
ces trois à mes trois collègues et puis
je vous donnerai une série de questions
à l'issue
merci et merci pour toutes ces
interventions sur la question des
concessions d'autoroute et le projet
route de France je veux dire
pour le président du Conseil
administration de la fille que je suis
jamais dire peu importe l'essentiel
c'est la recette qui sera affectée à la
fuite et la capacité à pouvoir financer
les infrastructures de transport la
question du modèle vous l'avez dit c'est
effectivement un échange que vous pouvez
avoir avec Clément bonne avec le
gouvernement et j'ai envie de dire pour
le président du Conseil munition de la
fille peu importe c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment j'insiste là-dessus l'essentiel
étant la recette qu'on pourra en tirer
demain quel qu'en soit le modèle qui
soit concessif ou qu'il soit un
établissement public national
sur la question des Pays de la Loire
il y a aujourd'hui une enveloppe qui a
été allouée dans le cadre du CPE donc je
pense que ça fait partie des discussions
notamment sur les questions du volet
mobilité des CPER je sais pas si
l'enveloppe correspond à aux attentes
qui étaient fixées je l'ai pas je l'ai
pas en tête mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui
ça relève effectivement des discussions
entre le préfet et la région aujourd'hui
et j'avoue que j'ai pas plus de
connaissances sur sur les discussions
qui sont en cours au niveau des Pays de
la Loire je voudrais élargir en fait
votre question au-delà de au-delà des
Pays de la Loire sur
pas simplement la question du de la
régénération du réseau mais aussi sur
sur le fonctionnement sur
sur Oui l'équilibre en fonctionnement du
du réseau ferroviaire
j'ai été frappé de des entretiens que
que j'ai eu sur
la péréquation qui est en train de
s'opérer à l'échelle nationale
entre les lignes LGV pour aller vite
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de lignes
de TGV était rentable ou en tout cas
avait un niveau de rentabilité qui
semble-t-il en raison des évolutions du
travail par exemple le télétravail cette
rentabilité est en train de diminuer
et
la question c'est où est répercuté cette
baisse de rentabilité d'une partie du
réseau elle est au lieu d'être
répercutée évidemment directement sur
les lignes les plus rentables qui
restent les plus rentables cette baisse
de rentabilité des lignes les plus
rentables se répercutent sur les autres
lignes c'est comme ça que je me suis
aperçu finalement parce que je suis
aussi maire de Dunkerque est très
inquiet de l'évolution du cadencement
entre Dunkerque et Paris par exemple
même entre Dunkerque et Lille que je ne
vous que je vois s'effondrer chaque
année je pense que vous devez avoir le
même sentiment pour les Pays de la Loire
et haut de France vivent vraiment la
même chose et je me posais la question
sur pourquoi finalement dans un pays
plus riche on a finalement un service
ferroviaire de plus en plus limité et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui cette question de
la péréquation et la baisse de la
rentabilité de ce qui était peut-être le
plus rentable de nos services
ferroviaires qui se répercutent sur des
lignes justement qui sont moins
rentables et aujourd'hui en train de
poser de vraies questions sur
l'évolution des cadencements sur
l'évolution du service qu'on peut avoir
et
c'est pour ça que je voulais élargir
votre question pas simplement au Pays de
la Loire je pense que la question du
service ferroviaire qu'on aura demain me
semble me semble véritablement poser en
tout cas en terme d'aménagement du
territoire elle est véritablement posée
aujourd'hui donc ça en tout cas je
tenais à le partager sur la question de
du financement de de la fuite la
question de quelle taxe qu'elle assiette
etc mon Dieu je me permettrai pas de
prendre votre place si elle s'est data
[Rires]
non non mais je pense que ce qui est
très important pour la fit et pas que
pour la fuite c'est la question de la
stabilité de la pérennité
je pense que c'est un élément essentiel
c'est comment on dépasse le principe de
la dualité budgétaire en fait les
infrastructures de transport ça
fonctionne pas avec la nualité
budgétaire on peut pas on l'a vu
d'ailleurs avec le plan de relance parce
que vous évoquiez des dérapages
calendaires de projets en fait à partir
du moment où on veut faire un plan de
relance même sur un an mais sur deux ans
mais sur trois ans ça ne répond pas à la
nécessaire visibilité des
investissements notamment sur leurs
règles et donc du coup
j'ai envie de dire
ma proposition est plus sur la forme que
sur la solution directe je pense que
pour l'avenir de la fuite ce qui me
paraît essentiel et monsieur le
président l'a dit quand il a parlé de la
TICPE et même la partie plan de relance
aujourd'hui qui n'est pas pérenne du
tout ce qui me semble nécessaire c'est
effectivement une taxe à 100% affectée à
la fuite et pas des bouts de taxes soit
je pense que c'est important parce que
je pense que là-dessus on peut peut-être
trouver un consensus politique pour ne
plus y toucher et donc du coup avoir
cette visibilité qui dépasse la nualité
budgétaire donc une taxe affectée à 100%
stable c'est-à-dire effectivement
à la différence de la TICPE qui va
baisser chaque année qu'est-ce qui nous
permet de garantir qu'on va avoir
effectivement une une vraie visibilité
et après la question de sa répartition
son assiette etc c'est là que je vous
renvoie la balle c'est pour ça que j'ai
énoncé cette question de justice sur qui
doit payer je me suis livré quand même à
un exercice je suis avancé un peu en
avant en disant que je vois pas pourquoi
il y a que l'autoroute qui devrait payer
je vois pas je pense qu'effectivement un
poids lourd je me suis engagé je te l'ai
dit je pense qu'un poids lourd qui
traverse la France et qui n'est pas sur
l'autoroute doit payer voilà je le pense
donc en intégrant une assiette
effectivement un peu plus large que
celle qui est aujourd'hui je me suis
aussi permis de dire que les billets
d'avion aujourd'hui combien 138 millions
c'est ça 138 millions de 2022 alors
qu'on a retrouvé le taux plein d'abrico
vide il me semble que la contribution de
l'aérien aujourd'hui aux infrastructures
de transport me semble quelque peu
limité voilà donc je vous livre des
pistes mais je pense que on
occultera pas un débat effectivement sur
qui doit payer contribuable dans les
territoires avec des sociétés de projet
versus
usagés
usagés de quoi d'ailleurs derrière et
effectivement
l'assiette qui est derrière tout ça
l'euro constant et le dérapage
calendaire je
vous remercie de cette proposition parce
que donc là on est sur 2022 on a fait un
rapport d'activité un petit peu comme
par le passé
mais je pense que du coup pour le
rapport d'activité 2023 et en 2024 donc
je m'engage est-ce que dans le rapport
d'activités de Lafitte on est
effectivement des choses en
neuroconstant vous avez raison parce que
aujourd'hui effectivement il y a des
augmentations de coûts qui sont
substantielles donc je le dis à la fois
la dgité et à la secrétaire général de
la fuite on mettra dans le rapport
d'activité 2023 donc pour 2024 un budget
en euro constant et on mettra
effectivement les projets qui ont pris
du retard par rapport et pas simplement
le taux d'exécution donc je vous promets
la transparence là dessus là aujourd'hui
je peux évidemment pas vous répondre
mais effectivement il y a eu des
dérapages commentaires sur certains
projets qui ont été reportés sur
d'autres effectivement on je vous
promets donc un acte de transparence
beaucoup plus important pour le rapport
d'activité 2023 donc merci de cette
proposition
si je vais donner la parole à Christine
erzog
merci président monsieur le Président le
préfet de la Moselle vient d'adresser sa
recommandation dans le tracé de la 31
bis à monsieur Clément bon le ministreet
transport à manger deux questions que
savez-vous du tracé préconisé et
s'agit-il d'une mise en concession
je vais donner la parole à Jacques
Fernique oui merci monsieur le Président
effectivement donc ce président de
Lafitte votre feuille de route a
évoluer changer de perspective avec les
annonces de la première ministre les
investissements colossaux donc du plan
avenir pour les transports donc
reprenant le scénario dit de
planification écologique du Conseil
d'orientation des infrastructures avec
on l'a dit on l'a déjà bien abordé c'est
important de contribution de
l'autoroutier et de l'aérien alors sur
l'autoroutier
avec la fin des concessions en cours qui
sont assis sur des investissements
massifs de mise en place des
infrastructures le COI parle dans son
rapport d'une perspective qui serait à
la baisse des recettes
de l'ordre de 50 à 70% dit-il au regard
des règles européennes d'aujourd'hui
donc ce qui paradoxalement risquerait de
dans les décennies à venir de favoriser
un mode qu'on cherche plutôt au
contraire à réduire la même façon le
président l'a dit de l'entrée la
décarbonation va mécaniquement réduire
le produit de la fiscalité sur les
carburants donc cette contribution du
secteur autoroutier pour les
investissements dans les transports
durables
j'ai entendu votre réflexion sur la
taxation des poids lourds et l'idée de
ne pas rester au seul périmètre des
autoroutes effectivement les nouvelles
perspectives de la révision de la
directive Eurovignette taxation
pollueur-payeur congestionnaire payeur
il serait possible de les exploiter à
l'avenir et d'une certaine façon la la
fameuse taxe alsacienne à venir et qu'on
attend pour être une sorte de
préfiguration qui nous rapprocherait du
modèle éprouvé par nombre de pays
européens
merci la parole est à Fabien Genet
merci monsieur le Président sont
peut-être moins des questions que deux
remarques de réflexion que je voudrais
partager avec monsieur le président de
l'Agence de financement des
infrastructures de transport après
l'avoir remercié pour sa présence et
ses premières explications je représente
un département la semône-et-loire qui a
une histoire très particulière avec
l'Agence de financement des
infrastructures de transport puisque
nous avons beaucoup beaucoup espéré
d'elle pendant très très longtemps
lorsqu'il s'est agit de financer cette
route de la mort qui était la route
entre Europe Atlantique et c'est vrai
que depuis quelques années lafit finance
très largement cette mise à deux fois
deux voies de cet axe dans ces deux
branches la branche nord qui va jusqu'à
Chalon-sur-Saône en partant de
Paray-le-Monial et celle qui va jusqu'à
Mâcon la branche sud c'était pour que
vous ayez toujours en tête le nom de
cette RCEA parce que non lorsque nous
aurons terminé cette phase
d'accélération très largement cofinancée
également par les collectivités locales
et je crois que
il faut rappeler le partenariat qui a
souvent l'État et la fuite ont souvent
l'État et lafit avec les collectivités
territoriales saluer les efforts de la
région Bourgogne Franche-Comté et du
département de la Saône-et-Loire sur ce
dossier de la RCEA il restera quand même
deux viaducs à mettre à deux fois de
voix et donc à co-financer et donc si
vous pouviez sur un petit post-it
monsieur le Président maître les noms
des viaducs de Charolles et de la roche
de ce Lutry alors la roche de celui très
c'est assez simple à souvenir il y a une
réputation historique importante et
celui de Sharon et tout aussi important
donc je ne doute pas que la vie sera
très sensible lorsque nous aurons à
négocié dans quelques mois cette
cette ce dossier pour terminer
complètement
cet aménagement et je suis élu à Digoin
une commune qui est à la frontière entre
la Saône-et-Loire et l'Allier et c'est à
Digoin que cette RCEA financé sur fonds
publics
non concédé devient la 79 l'autoroute
A79 qui a été inaugurée par le ministre
il y a quelques mois pour traverser
ensuite le département de l'Allier que
représente mon collègue Bruno rejoint
qui est assis juste devant moi et je
voudrais peut-être partager une
réflexion que nous nous faisons nous les
riverains de cette A79 puisque c'est une
des premières expérimentations je crois
de péage à flux libre
qui change quand même beaucoup la
perception même du péage puisque le
péage afflibre on ne s'arrête plus à une
barrière de péage on n'est plus arrêté
sur la route mais il y a un capteur qui
détecte la plaque minéralogique et
ensuite on peut payer soit avec le badge
soit en ligne et donc je m'interrogeais
si cette différence de d'appréciation du
pH dans votre esprit ça peut justement
aller dans ce que vous disiez sur une
évolution de qui doit payer est-ce que à
partir du moment où c'est la plaque
minéralogique finalement qui déclenche
le paiement est-ce que ça pourrait
faciliter ce que vous appeliez de vos
vœux c'est à dire un paiement sur
d'autres sur d'autres axes et voilà
c'était un élément que je voulais
partager avec vous et j'aimerais vous
entendre sur ces sur ces deux points
merci beaucoup merci monsieur le
Président je vous propose de répondre à
mes trois collègues merci
voilà rapidement d'ailleurs alors sur la
31 bises j'avoue que je n'ai pas
l'information a priori c'est une mise en
concession voilà mais je n'ai pas plus
d'informations sur le sur le tracé et
oui l'Alsace a été précurseur et je
trouve que c'est une bonne source
d'inspiration qui
mériterait d'être peut-être généralisé à
l'ensemble du territoire national je
trouve qu'on y trouve là des choses
intéressantes et ça rejoint aussi ce que
ce que vous venez de dire sur ce péage
afflux libre effectivement on a là
peut-être des pistes qui doivent pouvoir
permettre de de mobiliser plus
facilement des financements des
expériences existent de toute façon en
France même sur ces questions là et donc
l'idée de les généraliser me paraît
effectivement une bonne piste en effet
sur la RCEA on n'oublie pas
c'est prévu
merci je vais la parole à Philippe tarot
[Musique]
la relation entre la fuite et les et les
sociétés d'autoroute n'est pas au beau
fixe
administrateur de la fuite je m'inquiète
naturellement tout comme vous président
sur le non versement de la contribution
exceptionnelle des sociétés
concessionnaires autoroutières c'est ces
deux dernières années vous avez mis les
titres un contentieux est en cours il
sera certainement long on parle d'un
manque de près de 120 millions d'euros
en deux ans sans parler de 2023
dont je pense vous avez émis également
les titres sociétés en effet le
protocole de de d'avril 2015 signait
entre l'État et les sociétés
autoroutières comportaient un engagement
de versement des contributions
volontaires exceptionnelles à hauteur
d'un milliard deux sur 20 ans soit 60
millions d'euros indexés sur l'inflation
en contrepartie du paiement de de
l'échec de l'écotaxe quand on a souvent
parlé du rallongement des concessions le
ce genre d'activité de la fuite en 2022
est explicite car on apprend bien qu'en
2021 2022 alors que l'agence comptait
dessus les sociétés d'autoroute n'ont
rien cotisé pierre l'inflation de 100
pas être prise en compte alors que c'est
même société ont augmenté leur tarifs
comment la suffisamment répété ici
également de 4,75 l'année dernière
l'état sorti ses muscles à attaquer ce
nom paiement en raison des engagements
qui nous liés vous avez qualifié
l'attitude des sociétés autoroutières
d'un descentes la fuite est surtout le
dindon de la farce de cette affaire
privée de moyens qui serait bien
précieux quand on sait que ce sont les
collectifs budgétaires qui ont permis de
sauver les différents budgets de la
fuite je tiens le à le rappeler après
tout cela fait un certain temps
maintenant que les concessionnaires
d'autoroute se réfugient derrière des
contrats en béton pour relever les les
péages vous trouverez je pense en
première intention peut de monde capable
de protester contre les absences de
paiement mais en y regardant de plus
près je plagi alors pas totalement mais
juste sur ce point Bruno Le Maire lors
de son audition à l'Assemblée nationale
nous sommes dans un état de droit avec
un droit des contrats et de la propriété
la première attitude serait de rappeler
la responsabilité de la situation
actuelle revient quand même à l'état
c'est lui qui est incapable d'expliquer
cette décision à des Français sur les
effets d'une négociation favorable plus
sa lune qu'à l'autre des parties par
exemple demande-t-on à l'acquéreur d'une
voiture d'en revoir le prix à posteriori
au motif que sa valeur s'est envolée par
l'ancien propriétaire donc une certaine
indécence des sociétés d'autoroute
certainement une certaine indécence
également de l'État se réfugier dans une
attitude vexatoire alors qu'il a surtout
manqué de clairvoyance c'est une bonne
question ça
merci chers collègues je vais donner la
parole à Ronan dans tech
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président de Lafitte je voulais
attirer votre attention sur un point de
vigilance alors j'ai bien entendu la
proposition
d'avoir des recettes dans la durée et
qui ne soit pas des bouts plus des bouts
mais malgré tout pour l'instant on est
dans ce cadre là et Philippe tavaro
parlait de la contribution des
autoroutes moi j'attire l'attention sur
un risque qu'on imaginait pas alors qui
est une telle pas réel mais il vaut
mieux l'anticiper
les déclarations du président de la
République sur France Info la semaine
dernière 10 ans de l'attaque Chirac sur
les billets d'avion ça ne marchait pas
bah si ça marche c'est à peu près 400
millions d'euros cette année je rappelle
que c'est ce qui finance d'abord la
contribution de la France à la FD sur la
lutte que sur les ravages du sida et ça
veut dire cette année alors là les
chiffres varie donc j'ai bien vu les 138
millions dans votre budget mais la DGAC
vu l'envol du trafic aérien est plutôt
dans les 200 millions donc il y aura
peut-être une bonne surprise à la fin de
l'année à voir et 200 millions pour la
file c'est pas tout à fait rien donc je
pense que il faut qu'on soit vigilance
sur la défense de la réalité
l'efficacité de cette action Chirac
que j'avais défendu ardemment avec
Elisabeth borne avait repris et qu'on
pourrait y compris peut-être en
augmenter l'assiette au hasard les aides
privées enfin il y a quelques niches
comme ça qui échappent à la tax Chirac
alors de la taxirac finance derrière la
fuite et les besoins qu'on a donc je
voulais insister sur le fait d'être
vigilant sur le fait qu'elle ne soit pas
remis en cause au-delà de la déclaration
un peu sceptique et à mon avis
correspondant pas la réalité du
président de la République là la semaine
dernière et sinon évidemment j'abonde
dans le sens de dire que on peut pas
continuer à avoir des camions qui
traversent la France dans tous les sens
et qui ne contribuent pas et que nous
payons toujours et l'échec de l'écotaxe
et effectivement négociation
autoroutière qui était du grand
n'importe quoi
mais
et je vais donner la parole à
Jean-Claude Anglard
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président de la fuite
puisque vous avez des post-it je voulais
que vous Colliez post-it une autoroute
pour lequel l'État l'état ses engagé
vous savez sur 1000 km de route
nationale et parmi ces routes nationales
aujourd'hui il y en a que 2400
que les collectivités ont repris ont
repris en même parce que faute d'accord
avec l'État je vous parle de ceci pour
vous parler de la 68 qui est l'axe
Toulouse Lyon avec les 40 derniers
kilomètres qu'il reste à faire entre
Rodez et Séverac-le-Château pour lequel
le département de l'Aveyron en accord
avec la région ont décidé de prendre en
main la mise à deux fois de voix ou
d'une autoroute non concédée et la
question qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est
pour ça que je demande de mettre prendre
un post-it c'est que effectivement on a
du mal à voir la participation de l'État
sur ce sujet et donc je voulais avoir
votre avis sur ces questions ça a l'air
compliqué de négocier avec les temps en
ce moment sur ce sujet là voilà
malgré que je précise que cette
autoroute ou bien sûr l'assise foncière
est acquise par l'État toutes les prix
pour faire le pour dérouler le ruban si
je puis dire merci
merci je vais donner la parole à Madame
Préville
le président donc monsieur le Président
de Lafitte alors à l'heure où tout
change dans au niveau je suis par là
pour les transports puisqu'il nous faut
des carboner et avec raison bien sûr je
voulais rebondir sur ce que vous avez
dit à propos de votre enfin ce que vous
envisagez comme taxe pérenne qui sera
affecté à 100% à Lafitte et notamment
puisque il y a une part de votre enfin
du financement qui vient de la TICPE qui
va évidemment
diminuer de plus en plus avec l'entrée
massive des véhicules électriques qui
vont également emprunter les routes
comme les véhicules thermiques donc
comment va-t-on faire autrement dit
comment vous envisagez parce que ça
paraît très difficile mais il nous
faudra le faire quand même de mettre en
quelque sorte un petit peu plus de
justice dans dans les faits et également
parce que ça ça évidemment ça se croise
avec le problème des camions de manière
à ce que tous ceux qui empruntent les
infrastructures payent en quelque sorte
un écho et comment on pourrait
l'envisager et puis j'ai une petite
question subsidiaire puisque on en parle
très peu comment permettre le
développement du vélo et de son et de
son usage notamment puisque très peu de
gens finalement notamment en ruralité
l'utilisent pour épreuves de sécurité
routière tout simplement parce que ça
les vélos et notamment les vélos
électriques se sont bien vendus et parce
qu'on a besoin d'infrastructures pour
cela et notamment d'infrastructures
distinctes de simplement faire une ligne
au bord d'une route qui existe déjà pour
faire un chemin pour les vélos en
quelque sorte est-ce qu'on y pense à ça
et comment également envisager un
financement de peut-être alors d'abord
est-ce que ça coûte et combien de pour
cent de plus que une route pour des
voitures et également comment financer
également ces infrastructures qui
peut-être sont des infrastructures
d'avenir
importante voilà pour la décarbonation
merci monsieur le Président je vous
propose de répondre normalement à cette
dernière série de questions sur d'autres
collègues veulent intervenir merci
monsieur le Président effectivement je
confirme les propos de de Philippe
tabarrau c'est bien à manque à gagner de
122 millions d'euros sur sur les deux
années qu'on a pas perçu sur le
l'adjectif indécence j'entends j'entends
ce qui ce qui est dit effectivement sur
la dimension juridique et l'échec dans
lequel on est aujourd'hui
Roger prononcé small je fais le
distinguo entre le juridique et le
politique
c'est à dire qu'à un moment
quand on regarde les taux de rentabilité
interne pour les actionnaires de ces
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute on
peut se dire que c'était peut-être pas
le moment politique peut-être juridique
mais que c'était pas le moment politique
pour ces sociétés concessionnaires
d'autoroute de ne pas verser la CVE à la
fiche je pense qu'il y avait peut-être
un autre moment à choisir pour ces
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute et
c'est ça que j'ai qualifié de la
naissance ce moment là choisi pour
finalement faire du juridique à la place
du politique en tout cas aujourd'hui nos
concitoyens sont quand même un peu
choqués et je pense que c'est bien de le
rappeler mais sinon surtout le reste
évidemment je partage totalement ce que
tu as évoqué
sur ce qu'a dit Ronan et l'efficacité de
la taxe aérienne oui oui je partage
quand je disais les 138 milieux c'est ce
que perçoit l'affite j'aurais voulu en
avoir un petit peu plus voilà soit sur
la fuite 138 et 138 en 2022 138 en 2022
voilà et je pense qu'effectivement la
fuite pourrait en avoir davantage moi je
suis totalement d'accord pour élargir
l'assiette jet privé je trouve que ce
serait très pertinent je m'excuse ma
petite personne
mais je suis pour moi et je vois pas
pourquoi on élargirait pas la sienne à
partir du moment où on est sur des
mobilités carbonées allez je m'engage à
titre perso
sur la question de de Toulouse Lyon la
logiquement ce serait la réponse serait
de renvoyer au CPER la logique est là
aujourd'hui donc une discussion avec le
préfet il y a il y a des crédits qui ont
été alloués il y a les moyens de le
faire donc c'est vraiment un discussion
entre le président de Région et le
préfet pour savoir si les crédits
affectés sont le plus pertinent à ce
projet là là moi je j'en mets dire je ne
peux que renvoyer au niveau régional la
discussion entre le préfet et le
président de région sur ce sur ce
point-là et enfin sur le sur le vélo
donc il y a maintenant des financements
de la fuite c'est intéressant d'ailleurs
cette remarque sur le sur le vélo parce
que quand j'ai vous savez qu'il y a une
rapport de la Cour des comptes qui va
être
écrit sur sur la fuite la Cour des
Comptes est actuellement très examinée
lafit et le débat qu'à un moment donné
j'ai eu avec la Cour des comptes c'était
mais est-ce que c'est pertinent que la
fille de finance le vélo c'était l'une
des questions qui étaient posées est-ce
que finalement c'est pas les
collectivités locales qu'est-ce que la
fille devient faire là etc il y avait un
débat de cette nature à un moment donné
je pense que c'est important aussi pour
la fuite pour l'état d'être sur les
mobilités du quotidien et pas simplement
les grandes mobilités ou les grands axes
les LGV les grands projets etc et donc
maintenant effectivement la fille
contribue à
au vélo au développement du vélo et je
trouve que c'est plutôt une bonne chose
et ce que j'ai c'est ce que j'ai dit à
la Cour des comptes qu'effectivement
elle garde effectivement aussi un
financement pour ces mobilités du
quotidien même s'il faut le reconnaître
les collectivités locales sont en
première ligne je suis très
décentralisateur dans l'âme en tant que
mère de d'un caprice donc je vais pas me
être contradictoire avec moi-même
j'avoue que c'est d'abord aux
collectivités locales de effectivement
de s'engager sur les questions du
développement du vélo et je le fais à
Dunkerque donc voilà mais effectivement
qu'à un moment donné il y a un concours
de l'État via lafit à ses développements
là ça me paraît légitime en tout cas
pour ce qui me concerne manifestement
c'est pas forcément totalement partagé
mais moi je trouve que c'est à des
légitime que la fille puisse à la fois
aider le vélo mais aussi aider
d'ailleurs les transports collectifs
dans les agglomérations il y a aussi des
appels d'offres envoyées et des
financements des des autorisations des
autorités organisatrices de mobilité via
la fille que ça me paraît légitime c'est
pas toujours facile en terme d'exécution
parce que finalement on est sur beaucoup
on n'est pas sur des gros montants
affectés à un acteur on est sur plein de
petits montants affectés à beaucoup
d'acteurs et en termes d'exécution ben
là pour le coup quand on parlait des
dérapages calendaires il y a aussi des
dérapages de calendaires de cette nature
parce qu'évidemment quand vous quand
vous financez 50 collectivités il y en a
forcément toujours trois ou quatre qui
sont en retard donc c'est pas forcément
toujours simple mais en tout cas en
termes de symbolique être sur la
mobilité du quotidien y compris le vélo
c'est aussi une façon de participer à la
décarbonation des mobilités donc moi je
vous rejoins complètement là-dessus
merci monsieur le président
bien mes chers collègues merci Monsieur
le merci monsieur le Président
vous êtes prêté
aux réponses de nos questions réponses
précises je vous en remercie bien
compris et nous ont bien compris que
effectivement il faut que on puisse
réfléchir à des financements pérennes et
des financements qui vous soit affectés
et n'ont pas des brides de financement
ici ou là et je pense que c'est
important merci pour votre participation
merci